PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: I know
that from looking at
Numberphiles how many of the
viewer comment all the time
about the brown paper
that you use.
So I thought it'd be appropriate
to introduce the
Brown numbers.
This is short but sweet.
And I think it could be
a challenge for the
mathematically inclined
Numberphile viewers.
It's really straightforward.
Brown numbers are a pair of
numbers, a pair of integers--
let's call them m and n.
But they have a very
special property.
Their property is
the following--
that n factorial plus 1
must equal m squared.
Let me just remind you what
a n factorial is.
For example, 5 factorial
is 1 times 2 times 3
times 4 times 5.
So n factorial is just doing
that up to the integer n.
OK, so that's it.
That defines my Brown number.
It's a pair of integers, m and
n, such that n factorial plus
1 is m squared.
Let me just show you a couple.
So 5 and 4.
That's my m and n.
Let's just check it.
So 4 factorial--
n is 4--
plus 1.
Well that's equal to
24 plus 1, which is
25, which is 5 squared.
Another one is 11 and 5.
Let me give you another one,
Brady, 'cause, you know.
So 5 factorial plus 1 is equal
to-- what's 5 factorial?
Well, if is 4 factorial is 24,
5 factorial is 24 times 5,
which is 120.
Plus 1, that's 121.
And that's 11 squared.
OK?
So m is 11, so that's
why that one works.
So let's show you another one.
Another pair is 71
and 7, all right?
And you can go through
the same thing.
If you work out 7 factorial plus
one, that turns out to be
71 squared.
I've shown you three.
Yeah.
That's it.
BRADY HARAN: That's
all there is?
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND:
That's all there are.
That's it.
In fact, one of the greatest
mathematicians of the 20th
century, Paul Erdos, has
actually conjectured that
there are only three, and that
we won't get any more.
And so the challenge,
I thought, was I
mean, it's so simple.
Right?
Just go and try and find some.
BRADY HARAN: So if Paul Erdos
conjectures that there are no
more, what does that mean?
He's just said--
it's not proven?
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: No.
There's no proof of it,
Not that I'm aware of.
He must have some very good
reason for conjecturing it.
And I doubt that it was that
he's literally gone through
every single integer, although
he worked that hard.
He could well have.
There are great stories
about Erdos.
Quite a character, who for
many, many years, he was
effectively homeless.
He didn't have a home.
And what he would do is he
would show up at his
collaborator's house with his
bag of clothes, knock on their
door, and when they answered it,
say, "is your mind open?"
And that was it.
And they would collaborate with
him on mathematics, and
he would stay with them.
And then he'd move on
to the next person.
BRADY HARAN: I mean, I could
just make a conjecture right
here and now, and it could be
called Brady Haran Conjecture.
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: But that's
not really allowed.
What credibility does a
conjecture have to have before
it's really a conjecture?
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: I think
you have to probably
demonstrate that it's held in
lots and lots and lots of
situations where it
might fall down.
And that it's survived all of
the possible obvious tests
that you can make.
But of course, we can't--
we can't test this up to an
infinite number of numbers, so
it would actually need a formal
proof for it to work.